hi everyone my name's Alex Hutchinson
creative director on far cry 4 I'm Marc
Thompson I'm the narrative director on
far cry 4 nice to meet you nice to meet
you as well
and welcome to Kerr at our our our new
fictional location so in Far Cry 4 you
step into the shoes of AJ Gale who is
returning to the country of his birth
initially just to scatter his mother's
ashes before he gets caught up in what's
essentially a civil war Karev is a
fictional place based somewhere in the
Himalayas inspired by places like Nepal
and Bhutan I'm in a bunch of countries
from that part of the world so looking
out there you know one of the core
things of any open-world game that sort
of excitement and mystique and hope of
an open world is you know what is all
that smoke coming from you know what
temples are out there what secret
locations so we've we've we've peppered
the world with different places to find
all of them filled with loot and secrets
and collectables and all all that good
stuff and of course the the open world
of Far Cry is densely populated with a
variety of different animals beasts no
so that's some kind of yak I don't even
know what that animal was yeah I mean is
a yak with next-gen phone next gen fur
that's true it would visually modelled
hairs so you see here with like with the
eagle you won't see in this demo but you
can be attacked from above for the first
time in a far cry game so we tried
really dig in to play with verticality
to have threats above and below you and
obviously you can still get involved in
the ecosystem of the animals and hunt
and you can throw bait now yes to
attract animals and and stuff like the
the eagle stealing the morale of the
goat like it
it isn't scripted that's just what
happens at the intersection of those two
different AI systems talking to each
other the goal being that every player
tells himself a different story that
they get different surprises that they
have a different story to tell their
buddies when they they come to work the
next day or go back to school or
whatever
so a bunch of new tools in in Far Cry 4
one of which you'll see here is the
grapple we wanted to make something that
allowed you to clamor over those
annoying cliffs you sometimes came
across in Far Cry 3 and something will
also lean into the much more vertical
much more sort of mountainous regions we
were building in this game and I'm one
that was a pretty simple example but the
level designers get pretty crafty with
the setup we have these areas we're
calling Adventure zones in the new game
which will take you to places like
temples which you can see from afar and
force you to use the grapple in sort of
really interesting and different ways
the auto crossbow is a new stealth
weapon that we've introduced with Far
Cry 4 it adds a little more versatility
than the bow did in Far Cry 3 obviously
it sacrifices the long range for rapid
fire but it's still a super useful
stealth weapon this is one of my
favorite bits this this if you look down
when your may laying in the new game you
kick so you can do all kinda fun setups
such as that kicking things is hilarious
I expect people around the world to be
kicking rocks explosive barrels dead
bodies come November our goal really was
just to provide as many tools as
possible with their vehicles or animals
or weapons or you know goofy stuff and
let people fit them together any way
they want and we we've snuck a few
features in that fans of Far Cry 3 I
think they're gonna be surprised by
drive and shoot yes so drive and shoot
obviously it's it's a bit frustrating to
be chasing someone forever and have to
sort of drive in front of them pull over
and wait for him to get out so now in in
the vehicles you can drive and shoot
with any one handed weapon and you can
also do driving takedowns from any
vehicle which I really like so beside
your leaping from your vehicle into
another vehicle do horrible things to
and boot them out the side and then and
then continue on your merry way
you can now deliver death without even
leaving your seat so wingsuit is still
here it's really cool as you see and
actually when the space became more
vertical it actually became more fun the
mountainous environment means that
there's a lot more wingsuiting to be
found and hopefully you won't get it
before the middle of the game you will
hopefully will get it by the middle
that's the current plan that we are many
months away from watching you guys abuse
this online
so here you'll get a look a elephants
elephants are awesome probably my
favorite animal in the game weaponized
in many different ways you can drive
them into a rage watch them smash the
other characters in the world or you can
climber on top of one and drive it
through the gate yourself my favorite
animal is this is the human animal it's
very far cry 2 of you mark oh the shark
of darkness so co-op is a massive part
of the new game it's it's a one of our
big ways of opening up the open world
and letting you play any way you want so
basically when you ask your buddy to
join all the solo missions turn off and
you're left with all of the open world
toy the outpost the fortresses the
towers all the quests to play anywhere
you want and all that progress will be
saved within your game so you don't have
to go into another mode you don't have
to leave your game and you don't feel
like you're wasting your time all right
what do you think of the buzzer mask
which is a small one-man helicopter it's
very red no but it's cool because it
gives like this almost like developer
perspective on the world like II
normally in Far Cry 3 you can never
really see an outpost or you couldn't
engage with an outpost from this kind of
vantage point which is really cool so
the output the outposts are from Far Cry
3 where like the template for the the
fortresses they're kind of like bigger
better more badass version of the
outpost to a bad to paraphrase cliffy B
bad attitude
so imagine charging that vehicle
you know atop the elephant as opposed
you're just watching it happen we spend
a lot of money on the feature a lot of
money that we could have put that in a
video very expensive so thanks everyone
for watching we really appreciate your
time and we look forward to showing you
a whole lot more gameplay in the coming
months the game ships of course November
18th worldwide pre-order now for a free
upgrade to the limited edition includes
three extra story missions and a bonus
Impaler harpoon gun pre-order now Far
Cry 4 available November 18th 2014
you